[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to the installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the four founding members of
hogwarts
as well as the history of hogwarts the
finest school of witchcraft and wizardry
the world has ever known hogwarts was
founded at some point during the 10th
century
it was built hidden off somewhere in the
scottish highlands
the exact location is never actually
revealed and this was because the 10th
century
was a time of hardship for witches and
wizards during this time
every day witches and wizards were being
persecuted by muggles
who were intensely hostile when it came
to witnessing sources of magic
in order to further protect the staff
students and school itself
additional precautions were made in the
form of charms
helping to further conceal the school
from muggle trespasses
if a muggle would have just happened to
stumble upon the school grounds they
would only see ruins
and signs warning them to stay away
hogwarts was founded when four
10th century witches and wizards got
together and decided that they had
in the sorting hat's own words the
self-same yearning to make the world's
best magic school
these founders were godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw
salazar slytherin and helga hufflepuff
thus
hogwarts was born the name hogwarts
actually came from founder rowena
ravenclaw
but a dream where a warty hog led her to
a cliff
by a lake it's also been speculated this
is how they chose the location for the
school as well
after its establishment like with any
institution a crest was formed for
hogwarts
emblazoned upon the school crest are the
words draco
dormian nonquam to tilandis which
roughly translates to
never tickle a sleeping dragon rolling
revealed the true meaning of this motto
in an interview the name is just an
idiom derived from let sleeping dogs lie
it's a magnification if you will it
basically means
don't stir up trouble don't open up a
can of worms
don't stir up a hornet's nest and
definitely don't play with fire
if you tickle a sleeping dragon then you
are probably only causing problems for
yourself
problems that could be easily avoided if
you simply didn't
tickle a sleeping dragon anyway after
the founders
who were close friends founded the
school they decided they would each
create and head
their own house which would represent a
personality trait
and skill that they wanted to nurture
and it just so happened that despite
being close friends
each founder happened to value very
different things which created quite an
interesting and diverse array of
students
at the school gryffindor students
embodied bravery and
chivalry ravenclaw intelligence and wit
hufflepuff loyalty and fair play and
slytherin
the values of being sly and cunning and
for years
the hogwarts founders served as head of
their respective houses
and sorted students into their houses
manually however when it occurred to
them they wouldn't be around forever
they needed to come up with some sort of
way that they could continue to sort
students when they were no longer around
thus the sorting hat was born godric
gryffindor pulled his completely normal
hats off of his head
and made the suggestion to the other
founders that using their collective
magic
they enchant the hat and turn it into a
sentient being
it was important to the founders that
the houses they formed would continue to
follow by the beliefs from which they
were based
these virtues or inherent
characteristics are best summed up in
the sorting hats own words
by gryffindor the bravest were prized
far beyond the rest
for ravenclaw the cleverest would always
be the best
for hufflepuff hard workers were most
worthy of admission
and power-hungry southern loved those of
great ambition
essentially how it works is this upon
placing the sorting hat on your head it
will begin to analyze your mind
and place you in a house based on how
closely you resemble one of the four
founders
if the hat senses great bravery
gryffindor is a likely choice
if the hat senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice
if the hat senses that someone is a hard
worker hufflepuff is a likely choice
and finally the hat senses that someone
is hungry for power
then slytherin is a likely choice after
the sorting hat was put in place
it made things much easier for the
founders and it couldn't have come at a
better time
as the founders were beginning to have a
bit of a falling out but before we get
into that
let's take a look at the four founders
of hogwarts a little bit closer
first up we have godric gryffindor
godric gryffindor was a tall
muscular man with a lion-like mane of
hair this is representative of the
gryffindor crest
which contains a lion he was born in
none other than godric's hollow
which we know quite well gryffindor was
unusual as a wizard
and that he would often duel with the
sword rather than a wand
this was to give people a fighting
chance he was an extremely impressive
swordsman
and his sword the sword of gryffindor is
massively important in this series
the sword was forged for him by ragnarok
the first the finest of goblin
silversmiths
and it has been described as possessing
gleaming silver
with rubies the size of eggs in addition
to being an expert duelist
godric was also a charms master and
along with the other three founders
helped to enchant his hat which would
eventually become the sorting hat
godric was a noble man that helped fight
against muggle discrimination in the
wizarding world
next up we have salazar slytherin
salazar slytherin
you might have heard the surname was a
pure blood wizard that was born sometime
before 976
a.d most likely sometime between 930 and
960.
however given his immense power he may
have been around for much longer than
that
slytherin is infamous for his disliking
of muggleborn students
and was a strong proponent of having
only pure blood students
at hogwarts this philosophy was
ultimately passed on to
other slytherins his response to
muggleborn students attending the school
was to build the chamber of secrets
which concealed a basilisk that was
intended to purge the school
of these students he fundamentally felt
that muggleborns were unworthy of
studying magic
and gryffindor founder godric gryffindor
strongly opposed this notion
salazar slytherin was an extremely
powerful wizard he could produce all
sorts of dark charms and spells
and he was notably skilled at legitimacy
winemaking and basilisk breeding
next up we have rowena ravenclaw rowena
ravenclaw was a very close friend of
fellow founder helga hufflepuff
who was from wales there is much
speculation that both the location
and name of hogwarts were chosen by
rowena and she even came up with the
school's ever-changing floor plan
ravenclaw was thought to be the most
brilliant witch of her time perhaps even
more powerful than helga hufflepuff
and showed considerable talent in a
multitude of magical disciplines
she was even able to create and enchant
her own diadem which would enhance the
wearer's wisdom
this is the same diadem that her
daughter would later steal
rowena could also produce a patronus
charm and there was some speculation
that she was also versed in divination
she was a truly powerful witch who
placed a massive amount of emphasis
on knowledge and wisdom and last but not
least we have helga hufflepuff
helker was a round plump woman with
brown and blue eyes
she would often sport a smile and
frequently dawned a brown
or yellow dress unlike the other
founders though proud of her house
hufflepuff didn't have much of an
elitist mentality and just wanted
students to be educated
regardless of where they were sorted she
wasn't competitive
i'll teach a lot and treat them just the
same she is known for her vast abilities
in the realms of charms
particularly food-related charms which
was an area where she was unmatched
but one thing is for sure the hogwarts
founders all of them
are widely thought to have possessed
power that was entirely uncomparable
to most modern day witches and wizards
they were all charms and transfiguration
masters
expert duelists pioneers and more the
list goes on
they created the perfect environment for
students to become accustomed to magic
and the wizarding world as a whole
hogwarts was a safe place for all
that is after salsa southern had left
southern was an advocate of blood purity
had no interest in teaching
muggle-warned students this led to a
falling out with godric gryffindor
who was thought to have ousted southern
from the school in a jewel
after slytherin left peace and
prosperity returned to the school
environment
and muggleborns would no longer have to
live in fear but before slytherin left
the founders put together an impressive
curriculum for the students of the
school
truly leaving no stone unturned when it
came to magical abilities there were 21
subjects in total
astronomy charms dark arts defense
against the dark arts
flying herbology history of magic
potions
transfiguration arithmancy care of
magical creatures
divination muggle studies study of
ancient runes
alchemy ancient studies apparition art
ghoul studies magical theory and
xylomancy
if you want to learn more about these
subjects then i've got a video on it
called
all 21 subjects taught at hogwarts which
i'll leave a link for in the description
whichever way you want to look at it the
founders of hogwarts made one of the
greatest and longest lasting
contributions to wizard kind
that we know of and these four
characters were truly influential in
shaping the wizarding world
into the world that we know today that's
it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time what's life without a
little risk